moi j'estimerais un peu pas normal un
type qui a une bonne situation et puis
qui se marie pas mais le type qui a n'a
pas de situation pour fait pour moi je
trouve ça tout à fait normal c'est pas
des situation travailler la terre dans
des mauvais pays ce n'est pas une
situation ça c'est le dernier métier du
[Musique]
monde
alors Louis ça
va comme du viux pas trop
chaud bien s bon mainten bon al notre
petit pain ou
voilà
merci allez bonne
continuation à la
prochaine sa pas
quoi c'est à travers les yeux de Louis
Perin que nous allons voir revivre
albier
leeveux à travers sa voix nous
entendrons toutes les rumeurs du village
et de ses
[Musique]
habitants
Louis Perin qu'est-ce qui a changé pour
vous dans votre vie depuis 15
ans voyez en 59 alors là ma mère était
morte au mois de
février naturellement ça a été très
triste pour moi
quoi après après j'étais seul quoi de
deux c'est toujours deux quoi ça fait
une compagnie ça
fait il y avait certains travaux qu'elle
faisait elle continuellement quoi j'
allit pas m'en occuper elle vit pas que
je les fasse moi
elle elle venait elle prépar elle
préparait son feu le matin
elle faisait chauffer le café et moi en
même temps en même temps je donnais à
manger au bête par là à l'écurie par là
j'ai commencé à sortir le fumier je
venais boire mon café et puis après
elleelle avait son elle avait son chaude
pour donner boire au vache au cochon par
là il soignait tout
quoi
reste tout seul là vous savez il y a il
y a quand même des jours de cafard
quoi par la suite ça se ça se dissipe
[Musique]
quoi le temps il emporte
tout quand on a quelqu'un quoi les vieux
c'était quand même des gens de conscel
ils avaient av vécu la vie il avent ils
avaient tout vu ils avaient vu les
guerres ils savaient ce que c'était que
la
vie les vieux pour le fait c'était des
paroles d'évangile comme on
dit alors ça fait que maintenant des
fois il y a des moments où on est un peu
dé paysé on sent un peu tout drôle mais
faut faut regarder en arrière il y a des
moments où on a été plus malheureux que
ça il faut
comparer bon quand on est seul se
dispute avec personne
c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans une famille même qu'il
en aurait que deux c'est ver s'il y a
pas quelqu contrariété comme ça je
trouve les aussi si je fait une connerie
je trouve les à personne j'ai pas
de rendre
personne c'est ça qui est
bien il y a des gens il aussi bien de ne
pas se
marier moi j'estimerais un peu pas
normal un type qui a une bonne situation
et puis qui se marie pas mais le type
qui a n'a pas de situation pour fait
pour moi je trouve ça tout à fait
normal c'est pas des situation
travailler la terre dans des mauvais
pays ce n'est pas une situation ça c'est
le dernier métier du
monde la preuve c'est que ça disparaît
tout les un pour les
autres
si j'était pour commencer à 20 ans
naturellement maintenant que je
comprends la vie je je modifierais
tout j'aurais certainement quitté le
pays il manquit pas les situations dans
n'importe où dans l'armé dans la police
ou ailleurs comme des situations qu'il
fallait pas beaucoup d'instruction qu'on
était capable de les assumer quand même
nimporte tout principalement l'armée
c'est pas mauvais
l'armée une fois qu'on a pris le P il y
a pas les meilleures situations
là c'est les meilleurs là il vous
mettent pas à la
porte meilleur
celle-là VO
plan fait trois ch boulot
ouais
oua
allezal
alors est-ce que les gens d'albier
vendent beaucoup de
terrain de ce côtéci je crois que c'est
moi qui en ai le plus
[Musique]
vendu il y a beaucoup de gens le terrain
ils ont une spéculation part alors il
dit il faut pas le vendre maintenant il
faut attendre il faut attendre il faut
attendre qu'il attende un prix
exorbitant pour le vendre moi j'en ai
toujours
vendu parce que pour moi il il y en
avait toujours suffisamment du MO que je
suis tout seul il m'en resta toujours
assez quoi c'est pour ça que je le
regardais pas de si
près l'argent je le
place n'importe quoi les charbon la
cérgie c'est pas non plus pétrole tout
quoi tout ça c'est des placement très
sû il d'État n'importe garantis par
l'État tout ça
c'est ça fait pas des intérbit mais
enfin on peut compter dessus quoi 8 et
9% peut compter maintenant sans
peine
VZ par exemple un
terrainant une comparaison un terrain
de 1 million d'anciens
francs votre argent placé votre Milon il
vous rapportera quand même 80 ou 85000
anciens francs
quoi tandis que votre propriété d'un
million d'anciens francs vous y tirez TR
charges de fr au maximum 300 kg de foin
avec vos 300 kg de foin vous ferez pas
des
miracles pour pas tenir ni une vache
même pas une chèvre ni rien du
tout parce que vous vous rendez compte
pour hiverner une vache il faut on
compte 30 charges de
FO votre VO elle peut vous faire un
vaau il
faut P vendre 80 ou 100000 francs
quoi seulement avec la valeur du terrain
de de 30 charges de foin au lieu de de
de 80
de 80 100000 francs vous vous en avez
8 ou 900 par an vous comprenez la
différence que ça fait et sans vous
fatigué comprenez vous placez votre
argent
alors vous avez vos coupons vous retirez
vos intérêts c'est tout tandis que votre
votre terrain il faut le travailler il
faut il faut faer le foin il faut le
ramasser il faut le tourner des fois
plusieurs fois ça fait un travail fou
pour pas pour pour peu de revenu quoi
pour rien quoi c'est la comparaison
qu'il faut
faire votre terrain 2 million pour
apporter 80 ou 95000 anciens francs il
faudra ramasser le foin pendant combien
de temps pendant des milliers d'années
encore vous n'y arriverez
[Musique]
jamaisement il serait pas fait on aurait
tous été aussi
riches
ça n'a apporté aucune richesse au
pays pas des opérations fait dans la
logique
quoip du pays qui font partie des
commissions alors tout ce cher la
couverture complètement chez eu
quoi c'est ça les
autres
reste
moi le matin quand je me
lève une voiture qui est sur la route je
la je la vois pas mais je la sens déjà à
3 ou 400 m ce goût d' qu'on l' brûlé
là matin la fraîcheur vous savez ça
portein le goût de la voiture l'hiver
l'hiver c'est encore pire vous savez
avec la
neige le tunnel des des routes là dans
la neige alors c'est comprimé là ça
porte très loin le gage des
voitures ici la quiétude du pays c'est
le la trop grande circulation des
voitures
c'est ça qu' qu'on a gagné avec le
tourisme l'air
[Musique]
empoisonn moi pour vous citer un exemple
avec du 15 août et ben le soir j'étais
réellement malade parce que là dans
l'après-midi j'étais en contrebas de la
route et il est passé des milliers et
des milliers de voitures c'était
incroyable
presque
j'étais réellement malade ce
soir des voitures
Mo fait toutes les années quand je RAM
ce FO
là rappelez-vous que quand je suis
rentré j'ai fait avec l'alcool de et
tout ce qui
sen une envie
F quand avait pas la route dans ces
montagnes là alors il y avait encore des
coins o l'air éta pe près pur l'été
maintenant c'est
fini pour fait du développement dans le
dans l'ensemble bon pour l'instant et ça
se passe tout en famille pour l'instant
il y a pas les promoteurs immobiliers
des étrangers d'ailleurs c'est la seule
chose qu'il faut pas jamais laisser
venir implanter
là les gens du pays c'est pas pareil t
les étrangers vous savez eux ils
voudront être chez eux complètement et
ils font pas gagner un centime au gens
du pays ils ont leur personnel pour
l'année quand il les enlèvent de l'â des
fililleur il faut pas compter d'aller
s'embusquer
là-dedans l'agriculture l'agriculture et
le tourisme ça ne va pas ensemble ça va
être il y en a un qui va tuer l'autre ça
va être le touriste qui va tuer
l'riculture mais enfin c'est c'est
Constantin c'est Rambo il y a du
tourisme il y a aussi de la culture oui
parce que le tourisme n'est pas encore
suffisant pour les faire vivre pas
encore assez développé pour eux ça
viendra au moment ça sera assez
développé ils pourront vivre avec le
tourisme sans s'occuper de la terre
c'est ce qui va se passer parce que
quand il y auras plus que les jeunes
pour réellement rien que les jeunes pour
travailler la terre alors là c'est cuit
là c'est fini pourquoi pensez-vous que
les jeunes vont vont quitter ou
abandonner le travail en général ils
n'ont pas été dressés pour ils ont pas
ils ont pas été le travail de la terre
il faont encore un peu de la culture là
ils pourront faucher avec une moto
fauchuse par là la bouré il y en a les
les 3/4 et demi qui savent pas la
bourrer dans les
jeunes les Fauch avec une fauchse c'est
impossible pour ils ont jamais fait ça
alors il faut cher quelques morceaux
quelques beau morceaux avec la machine
et puis le reste ça
reste est-ce que vous regrettez vous que
le travail de la terre disparaisse dans
la commune
d'albier faudrait pas que ça s'étende
partout parce que ça VI ça tournerait
peut-être tragique à la
langue qutité de
maison là où il y a pas de où il y a pas
de descendance quoi là là il y a pas de
problème ça ça ça ça s'éteint comme une
chandelle comme siz moi après personne
il y aura
personne si les voisins là ils sont pas
mariés il y aura
personne
même dans les familles où il y a encore
des enfants on n'est pas s restant par y
a des grosses familles qui é tout à fait
gross qui sont partis c'est
disparu portes sont
fermé maintenant il y en a plus qu'une
ambition
P sur la ligne de
démarcation c'est l'arme comment on
[Musique]
dit